[Music]
hey there welcome to the show I got a
dark suit on but we got a bright cast of
characters including these the
grandmother just shiver 80th birthday
power lifting and unbelievable amount of
weight it's a grandmother also family
that fled Ukraine moved to the U.S but
their youngest daughter felt that
someone was left behind well how did
strangers reunite them with their
missing family member we'll explain plus
you may know him as Draco Malfoy but
after Tom Felton is more than his iconic
Harry Potter character and he opened up
to our Anthony Mason about life lessons
and also love all that plus our
heartwarming videos the ones you just
gotta see you know what you're doing
you're watching The Uplift
[Music]
hey there I'm Tony decopo and this is
the uplift the show that lifts you up
for at least the next 30 minutes
hopefully a little bit longer you and me
as well and we are going to start with a
family that left Ukraine fled really
moving to California but unfortunately
there was one beloved family member left
behind
strangers then pulled together to help
with the family reunite once again here
is Caitlin O'Kane with the story
fleeing a war-torned country means
packing up your family and leaving the
rest behind your home your business even
your pets
our car was full of us so we could not
take any animals that we have we asked
my
brother-in-law to watch over the animals
and the youngest one at Nessa
she was crying every time she says I
want to go back home my animals there my
cat's there and we couldn't help her
when the best in our family decided to
leave Ukraine and come to the U.S they
promised agnesa they would adopt a cat
once they got there
through a website that matches refugees
with sponsors Maria met Jeffrey Peters
who has dedicated his life to working
for Charities helping a family from
Ukraine move to the U.S was his new
Mission can you imagine your life being
turned upside down and you have to leave
a country you've never left before right
on an airplane you've never done before
arrive in a new country learn a language
I mean just it's like from starting from
scratch only it's on steroids it's like
everything moving 100 miles an hour when
they arrived in Cloverdale California
they realized Jeff wasn't the only one
there ready to give them a warm welcome
the house was an empty house and so we
contacted all of our friends in the
community here in Cloverdale California
and literally they furnished the entire
house from top to bottom beds for every
person in the family
kitchenware utensils
slates my grandchildren actually went to
the airport and greeted them as well in
Cloverdale there wasn't just a new home
waiting for them there was a new family
I couldn't find Awards like
when we saw them they become like our
father and mother
like we I call him like adopted father
since coming to the US the family has
made many changes they've gotten their
California driver's licenses the girls
have enrolled in school the two eldest
in junior college and Alexander is
working to restart his career selling
and installing wallpaper they even
adopted a new cat but agnesa still felt
one thing was missing their beloved cat
arseni but as fate would have it Maria
befriended a flight attendant on the way
to the U.S who knew people who could
help and I asked her if she knows
something about the cats how how cats
can fly and what documents
cats need and she says
I don't really know about this but my
friend who is another flight attendant
from Hawaii she must know everything
about that that flight attendant new
people who worked for animal rescue they
contacted someone from the rescue who
was already in Europe on vacation she
volunteered to tack on some extra travel
to pick up arseni and bring him all the
way to California she brought the cat
back to Greece and from Greece to
Montreal and from Montreal to Seattle
and from Seattle to San Francisco it was
an act of kindness that made their
family whole again as they work to
rebuild their lives we are surrounded by
good people here that was much easier
when somebody is welcoming you and say
like feel here like you are in your own
home that was really
unbelievable for us
the Ukrainian and the American flag side
by side you see that a lot these days
but moving on for now to our next story
it's about a grandmother who proves that
age is only a number
but 15 years ago she decided to change
her life she's now 80 years old stronger
than ever there's another number in this
story it does matter here's Meg Oliver
when nor Langdon turned 65 she needed a
change I was in bad shape I weighed too
much
and I couldn't go up and down the stairs
without getting tired Langdon went to
Royal Oak Gym in Michigan and asked Art
little to train her in power lifting
when you first met Nora did you think a
world champion was standing no ma'am
little was hesitant but Langdon was
hooked determined to master all three
events in the sport
she trained for two years before
competing now just shy of her 80th
birthday the grandma holds more than 20
National and world records with personal
bests of 413 pounds in the squat
381 in the deadlift and 203 for the
bench press she upped the game not only
for people her age but for everybody the
young people they get involved because
of her
competing in November Langdon hopes to
lift a thousand pounds across all three
events how old do you
feel I feel like I'm 50.
never
lifting her spirits to new heights all
right coming up all right coming video
performing videos
and got a lot of Harry Potter and
another real life Harry Potter the star
of whoa co-star Draco Malfoy later in
the show you're watching The Uplift
welcome back to the uplift and welcome
back to our heartwarming videos ones you
just gotta see and we are going to begin
with an especially good winning shows a
woman named Melissa Bradshaw doing
cartwheels at the Indie app Indianapolis
Zoo and there's a dolphin there behind
her that seems to be imitating every
single flip
is she imitating the dolphin or is it
dolphin imitating her I don't know
either way it's beautiful
to our next story a dog named Teddy got
very excited for Halloween this year
golden retriever gets excited about
everything to be honest who's dressed up
in costumes throughout October including
let me see if I can get this right
Batman Yoda from Star Wars a
construction worker uh and a Harry
Potter as in you know Harry like you got
a lot of hair there's that one okay
that's one way to hold the wand coming
up actor Tom Felton opens up about life
after Harry Potter the real Harry Potter
uh and the lessons he's learned since
the Beloved series plus a man who was in
and out of the hospital for years
battling cancer what credits what does
he credit for helping him overcome the
odds and walk down the aisle
we love love stories here at the uplift
and this next one is about high school
sweethearts who had to overcome many
many odds to end up as a married couple
here's Christina capatitis with more on
their Journey down the aisle
there are many famous sayings about love
love is patient love is kind love
conquers all but does love have the
power to heal high school friends turned
College sweethearts Zach and Maddie
would tell you it does for 24 years Zach
was a healthy athletic man then he
started experiencing sharp chest pains
and noticed he had a swollen lymph node
in his neck so he went to the ER and was
diagnosed with stage four blood cancer
it was probably like the worst nightmare
I could ever think of six chemo sessions
and five months later Zach went into
remission but the doctors cautioned
there was still potential for relapse to
celebrate being cancer-free Zack and
Maddie decided to take a trip to Panama
City Beach Florida their favorite
vacation spot I had a bought an
engagement ring for her I just thought
it was like a perfect setting for us
because the beach is our favorite place
when he proposed to me he had just
talked about how
his whole life he had never believed in
soul mates and that the day that he met
me and over the challenges that we've
gone through when he was diagnosed with
cancer made him believe that soul mates
do exist the couple spent the next five
months enjoying their new engagement as
best they could not knowing that their
Bliss was to be short-lived one night
Zack lost feeling in his legs and the
couple learned that what they had feared
most had happened Not only was the
cancer back this time it had spread to
his brain and there was a tumor on his
spinal cord we had met with our
neurologist that night and he pretty
much told us that if we don't operate
you in the next 24 hours you're probably
going to be paralyzed for the rest of
your life they had sent me home that
night and I couldn't walk into the house
and my father-in-law and Maddie had
actually had to drag me into the house
and I remember looking down at my feet
and they were just like dragging across
the garage floor and that was really
scary and although surgeons were able to
successfully remove the tumor he lost
all feeling from his chest down and
couldn't do anything without assistance
so he had to go to a Rehabilitation
Hospital
and relearn how to write relearn how to
tie his shoes relearn how to use the
bathroom relearn how to do every single
daily task and at this point he's also
going through chemotherapy again so he
would start to make progress and then
get hit with chemo and then like take
two steps back after months of hard work
the rehab started kicking in Zach was
getting stronger then he found out that
chemo had stopped working you kind of
like lose hope a little bit the next day
Zach started a new type of chemo and his
colon ruptured doctors made a 10-inch
incision from the top of his abdomen all
the way down to his groin they didn't
know whether he'd even make it through
surgery but defying the odds again he
did that was probably the hardest part
of the whole journey was that month and
I pretty much had lost
all my fight and I really wanted to give
up they had to put a a tube of my nose
to you know suck up the fluids that were
constantly building up because if that
wouldn't happen I'd constantly vomit we
really didn't know how much time we had
left the couple decided to make the most
of the time Zach had left and planned an
impromptu wedding in 48 hours on the
oncology floor we didn't want to lose
out on the opportunity of being able to
marry each other I wanted to make sure
we didn't have any regrets I had my
wedding dress already picked out and
bought from when we initially got
engaged the nurses had come in on their
day off and they did my hair and my
makeup and they safety pinned my dress
to me because it wasn't even hand or
tailored to me yet they put together
bouquets and a cake and they played our
wedding song as I was walking down the
hospital aisle with my dad the elevator
doors had opened up and I see my dad
standing there with tears in his eyes
and I looked down the hallway and there
were so many nurses and doctors and
other patients in their patients
families there and
everybody was cheering me on as I was
walking down the aisle and it was just
one of the most surreal moments Zach was
sitting there and he was sitting in his
wheelchair and he was so skinny at this
point and so weak
and was hooked up to machines he was on
a feeding tube at this point and was
getting chemo and
I just remember he looked so handsome
the wedding
really put a lot of life into me yeah
seeing it was so uh beautiful in that
dress walking down the aisle really gave
me the the strength that day to actually
stand up and do our first kiss going to
the wedding I was like extremely weak on
pain pumps and everything like that and
seeing my wife walk down the aisle and
in a beautiful wedding dress just you
know just so happy to marry me it gave
me like a lot of drive and fight for you
know the rest to come I forgot about
everything else and I was only focused
on her and getting married even though
he couldn't stand up we still like
danced around him shortly after the
wedding and after almost a year at the
hospital Zach was finally released he's
being monitored closely but he's no
longer receiving treatment and the
cancer is gone
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
good job I really owe my life to her and
keeping me alive and giving me like in a
positive mindset throughout all this and
keeping me in like a good fighting
Spirit to get through everything it's
made our love a lot stronger and it's
definitely made it unconditional there
were days where he was a lot stronger
than I was and there were days where I
was a lot stronger than he was so I
think that we both kind of fed off of
each other modern medicine is miraculous
but so Zach and Maddie would tell you is
love that's just something I've done
this whole time and it's just constantly
think about Maddie and stay and fight
for Maddie stay in this world for Maddie
because she needs you
it's a wise couple we do love love
coming up if you know him for playing
Draco Malfoy and Harry Potter Tom Felton
has much more than that character in him
in his real life how he overcame
obstacles after finding Fame next
he's known for playing Draco Malfoy in
Harry Potter but now Tom Felton has a
new role and a book about the lessons
he's learned in between Anthony as in
Mason met Malfoy in London to talk about
that new memoir
your theater is right up here yes it
couldn't really be more uh Central to
the madness and Chaos of London in
London's Piccadilly Circus this summer
Tom Felton the actor best known for his
work in the Harry Potter films
was making his West End debut your name
up in lights
it's still surreal now to be honest with
you
uh it's a pinch me moment every morning
it's pretty cool it doesn't get old
Felton was co-starring in the hit
mystery 222 a ghost story If ghosts
exist why are there absolutely loads of
them foreign
acting since he was age nine Landing
roles in the borrowers he don't have a
father we have a map and Anna and the
King
I was born enthusiastic rather than
talented Felton writes in his new Memoir
beyond the wand Harry Potter has come to
Hogwarts at age 12 that enthusiasm
landed him the role that would change
his life Draco Malfoy how early on did
you realize how long this was going to
go for
if none of us did Scared Potter over the
next 10 years in all eight Harry Potter
films Felton played Draco Malfoy
Harry's sneering Nemesis at Hogwarts
draco's fabulous sneer yes how did you
develop that draco's snare really comes
from my grandfather his grandfather had
a cameo as a wizard in the first film he
was also Felton's chaperone so he sort
of developed this idea uh in the mirror
with me one day sort of always always
constantly looking down your nose at
everything slightly
and then the tiny hint of a flared
nostril and then a tiny hint of a smile
ah come to see the show
they're on screen animosity Felton was
close with his castmates especially Emma
Watson we've always had a sort of
strange love together not and the
romantic way that some people would like
to think
um how would you describe it then well
best of friends yeah people that speak
the same language similar sense of humor
she's got a wicked sense of humor no the
legendary older actors in the films
however Felton often found intimidating
Ray fines who played the Demonic
Voldemort had an otherness Felton says
that set him apart from everyone else on
set he's also when in full
y mode if you will he's incredibly fluid
and flowing and you never quite know
where he's gonna go next which is
quite frightening to be honest
in the climactic scene of the last film
Draco had to walk towards Voldemort
Draco
well done
and then he hugged you that's when
that's when the hug happened yeah and
then you didn't know he was going to do
that no idea in my head I'm going what
is he doing yeah incredibly awkward
um but also chilling
don't touch anything Draco
you Felton Jason Isaacs who played
draco's father could be almost as
frightening he could actually switch
into character like that
smiling and lovely and being Jason and
the moment they said the words action he
just turned and gripped me for for the
first time as Lucius and I was I was
terrified immediately what did I say you
still call Jason Isaac's dad
occasionally I do
in fact I'm very excited he's coming to
see the play um oh is he tonight oh wow
yes so he's he's actually flown back
from filming just to see it he's a very
proud father he posted their reunion on
social media as he was wrapping up 17
weeks on stage Felton reflected on his
toughest farewell the end of Harry
Potter the last day was hard wasn't it
yes it was a very Bittersweet goodbye I
can't I can't drive past the Eastern
Studios without
you can't no I can barely talk about it
really
is a
it was our second home after a decade of
playing Draco Felton moved to Los
Angeles in 2012. he loved auditioning
for new roles don't get me wrong you go
into a panic spiral every time
um but you proved to yourself that I
can't eat this don't you know food when
you see it he landed Parts in Rise of
the Planet of the Apes
but seduced by the LA lifestyle he began
drinking heavily I was hiding from
something he writes in beyond the wand
myself perhaps
friends finally staged an intervention
you were angry at that moment
yes I was furious at the time my brother
said sometimes you need to have a
breakdown before a breakthrough happens
um so something the wheels needed to
come off somehow a little bit
um did you feel like the wheels would
come off
in that moment definitely because I
couldn't see really what they were
talking about but his lawyer's words
would get through to him what did he say
he said something along the lines of
Tom I think this is the 12th
intervention that I've been to and
six of those are dead don't be the
seventh yeah
that kind of hit me Felton agreed to go
to rehab but then one night he broke out
he ended up just walking down the beach
yeah a lot clicked when I managed to get
down to the water what clicked
that I needed but I needed help and I
was willing to accept it Tom Felton
eventually returned to London where he's
been thriving and Harry Potter is still
a big part of his life you're amazed
that this is actually bigger now than it
was then
it's incredible most fans who say hello
to me or shout Draco whatever
they weren't born when the first films
were being made is it important for you
to keep saying thank you yes the Potter
fan flame is not going anywhere anytime
soon and I'm I'm the first one to
to celebrate that and be very grateful
Draco Malfoy AKA Tom Felton who knew he
was a good guy in the end and that is
our good show we have come to the end I
hope it brightened your day I hope it
lifted you up if it didn't know what I
always say reruns totally free you're
gonna go find some good news
[Music]